Saudi Arabia is universally known for
their massive oil reserves and extreme
wealth their Flagship company Saudi
aramco is worth over 2 trillion dollars
and has annual earnings exceeding a
quarter trillion dollars they also
apparently have 266 billion barrels of
oil which works out to roughly 1 6 of
the entire world's reserves with such
large reserves you would think that the
country would avoid importing oil like
the plague but Saudi Arabia has actually
been doing the exact opposite they've
actually been doubling down on oil
imports since June and this isn't the
first time Saudi Arabia has leaned into
Imports either historically Saudi Arabia
has embraced oil imports whenever they
need more oil but why would a country
like Saudi Arabia ever need more oil
wouldn't it always just be cheaper to
use their own I mean just take a look at
Venezuela who is able to offer
subsidized gas for just 8.4 cents per
gallon Saudi Arabia on the other hand
comes in at 2.34 cents per gallon which
is really not that impressive for the
world's oil Kingdom so why in the world
is Saudi Arabia importing oil and why
are gas prices so high in Saudi Arabia
itself
one of the primary reasons that Saudi
Arabia turns to Imports is because of
the different types of oil to most of us
are all good oil probably appears the
same but there's actually six different
types of oil these oils are usually
classified into three main categories
which are light medium and heavy the
attribute that differentiates these
three categories is a scale to call the
API gravities that essentially ranks
these oils based on their densities in
comparison to water Within These main
categories you have two sub-categories
which are sweet and sour these
subcategories are reflective of the
given oil sulfur content the lower the
sulfur content the sweeter the oil
technically we do have processes to
convert between the various types of oil
I mean it really just comes down to
removing impurities or varying the
sulfur content but more times than not
it's cheaper to use these oils in their
natural state than try to convert them
into a different state light crude oil
is generally the most valuable type of
oil given that it's the easiest to
refine it and has the largest amount of
use cases this is the type of oil that
is used to produce gasoline Diesel and
aviation fuel in other words this is the
type of oil that runs the world heavy
crude oil on the other hand it is also
pretty useful given that it's what's
used in most manufacturing processes and
crude plays an essential role in
producing Industrial Products such as
asphalt and Plastics with the light and
heavier out of the way that leaves us
with medium crude oil which is usually
the most underappreciated medium crude
is actually the most common type of oil
but there aren't very many use cases for
it in its natural state so medium crude
is usually distilled to create light
crude in terms of the subcategories
sweet food is what the world craves in
and sour crude is generally just
converted it into sweet crew with that
being said the most valuable type of oil
has historically been a light sweet
crude due to the exponential growth
within the automotive and Aviation
Industries but as the world's oil
consumption started to stabilize it
became evident that oil Giants may have
diverted too much of their focus to
light sweet crude we were starting to
get into a position where there was an
oversupply of light crude and then under
supplier of heavy crude so while light
speed has historically demanded a
premium much of that premium has slowly
eroded away over the years and in some
cases I could even trade at a discount I
know that all of that info may have been
a little dense but I think it's
important in understanding a country's
complex oil needs now that we have a
basic technical understanding regarding
the various types of oil let's delve
into why Saudi Arabia Imports oil
given the success of Saudi Arabia's oil
industry I don't think you'd be
surprised here that their reserves
primarily consist of like crude Saudi
Arabia does produce five different
grades of oil which are Arabian heavy
Arabian medium Arabian light Arabian
extra light and Arabian super light but
as you can see three of these are simply
subcategories of light crude which makes
the country prone to imbalances
something else to note is that virtually
all of Saudi Arabia's oil reserves are
sour oil the only exception to this is
the offshore esophonia oil field
fortunately this happens to be the
world's largest offshore oil field but
even saphonia is only able to produce
roughly 1 million barrels per day now
that's not a bad amount by any means but
in comparison to Saudi Arabia's total
oil output of 10 million barrels per day
that's only 10 meaning that 90 of Saudi
oil is sour so while Saudi Arabia has
enormous oil Reserves at the vast
majority of it is light crude sour oil
naturally this leads to imbalances which
Saudi Arabia has to make up for using
Imports also something that we should
note is that Saudi Arabia is not only
looking to make up for internal
imbalances but International imbalances
you see it even though Saudi Arabia does
not have the world's largest oil
reserves they've become the dominant
voice within the industry and they're
trusted around the world as the oil
Bankers Saudi Arabia takes this
responsibility extremely seriously and
for them this has become a matter of
Pride and control now this does not mean
that if Botswana has a shortage of oil
or if gas prices are skyrocketing in
Europe Saudi Arabia is gonna come to the
rescue but what this does mean is that
they're willing to do whatever it takes
to deliver the oil that they have
promised to deliver and this includes
important oil to make up for Supply
slash production shortages a perfect
example of this was in 2019 when they're
all processing facilities were attacked
drones were used to severely damaged oil
facilities in the upkayic and curries
which disrupted the vast majority of the
countries of all output a rebel group
from Yemen would claim responsibility
but given the sophistication of the
ordeal Saudi Arabia suspects that it was
actually Iran Iran has profusely refused
involvement but really the identity of
the perpetrator is not really important
for what we're talking about the point
is that Saudi Arabia's oil facilities
were significantly damaged which lowered
output by 5.7 million barrels per day
given the circumstances I don't think
anyone would have blamed Saudi Arabia if
they fell short of their delivery
numbers but despite this Saudi Arabia
would import oil from a bunch of foreign
oil producers to could give customers at
every drop of oil they've ordered pride
in no doubt plays a role in this
decision but there's a substantial
amount of strategy here as well by
stepping up to the plate even during a
national crisis Saudi Arabia has shown
the world that they will stop at nothing
to deliver on their promises and this
has given the world a very little reason
to diversify away from Saudi Arabia now
imagine if Saudi Arabia didn't import
oil sure no one would have blamed them
but Saudi Arabia's customers would have
probably Diversified to other oil
producers for their own security but
stepping up Saudi Arabia was able to
maintain the Loyalty of their customers
and more importantly maintain control
and at the end of the day that's the
name of the game
keeping controller and the maintaining
pride is not the only reasons that Saudi
Arabia Imports oil another key reason
for Saudi Imports is opportunity and
profits and with the whole Russia
situation going on this Avenue is more
open than ever by now I'm sure all of
you guys are familiar with the Russian
oil sanctions the West has decided to
boycott Russian products in order to
hurt them economically and quote unquote
teach them a lesson and given that
Russia was the world's second to largest
crude oil exporter only beat not by
Saudi Arabia themselves this has
disrupted the global oil supply chain
leading to the super erratic gas prices
that we've seen over the past several
months while this is terrible news for
westerners this has been a godsend for
all producing countries like Saudi
Arabia who have seen record profits
higher oil prices aren't the only area
in which Saudi Arabia is profiting
though even though Global oil prices
have been skyrocketing Russian oil
prices have been falling off a cliff
given that no Western country wants to
touch their oil on average it appears
that Russia is offering a 30 discount on
their oil in comparison to the global
Benchmark if Saudi Arabia really wanted
to push the envelope what they could do
is import Russian oil at a 30 discount
and then tell it as their own at a
market price but it's more than likely
that they're not doing this and it's
simply not worth risking an
international oil Partnerships for an
Arbitrage opportunity but these rules
are only applied to exports to Western
countries many of Saudi Arabia's
customers are not Western countries and
they do not care about the source of
their oil two of Saudi Arabia's largest
customers are China and India and these
guys have actually gone out of their way
to import Russian oil directly so they
definitely do not have a moral dilemma
when it comes to Saudi Arabia
repackaging Russian oil someone else who
doesn't have a moral dilemma with
Russian oil is Saudi Arabia themselves
it makes very little sense to use their
own oil which can be sold for top dollar
to Western Country series when you can
import Russian oil at a 30 discount it's
honestly a no-brainer and it's no wonder
that Saudi Arabia has been leveraging
this strategy the real losers in this
situation are everyday westerners who
are paying top dollar for Middle Eastern
Oil not to mention Western countries are
basically still supporting Russia just
through a proxy now this isn't to say
that Russia isn't being heard or that
the sanctions aren't effective I mean
they're literally having to sell their
oil for a 30 discount so clearly they're
being hurt but the thing to note is that
Western countries that aren't just
hurting Russia but they're also hurting
themselves and the ones that are truly
benefiting are the countries in the
middle like China India and of course
Saudi Arabia
foreign
ports may seem confusing at first glance
given their massive oil reserves they
actually make a lot of sense when you
take a closer look first of all there
are several different types of oil and
Saudi Arabia primarily only has light
cooled sour oil so they often have to
import oil to make up for internal
imbalances but it's not just internal
imbalances that they're looking to make
up for all of Saudi Arabia's power
originates from their dominance on the
global oil markets if they lose this
dominance they also lose their power and
influence on the world stage which is
obviously not something that Saudi
Arabia wants to do to keep their power
Saudi Arabia is willing to go to extreme
lengths to meet their production numbers
and deliver to their customers and yes
this includes importing oil at a loss to
make up for production shortfalls
imported oil does not always have to be
expensive or undesirable though Russian
oil is extremely desirable right now
given that it's selling for a 30
discount for Saudi Arabia can't just
turn around and sell the same oil to
Western countries they can use it
themselves and sell it to neutral
countries this way they can save all of
their own oil production for Western
markets where can be sold for absurd
profit margins allowing Saudi Arabia to
profit one billion dollars on a daily
basis and that's why Saudi Arabia is
importing a record amounts of oil would
you be willing to Arbitrage between
Russia and the West comment that down
below also drop a like if you're hoping
that these oil games and sooner rather
than later and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions are logically answered but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one